This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Anyone who has had kids knows that they go through obsessive phases that can last anywhere from a few days to several years. I went through a lot of phases growing up. That's producer Emmett Fitzgerald. There was a brief train phase, then in preschool I was obsessed with farming equipment. I could list obscure European tractor brands off the top of my head, like an old Italian wheat farmer. But I think my most intense obsession, like many kids, was dinosaurs. I knew more about dinosaurs at the age of five than I do now.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。任何有孩子的人都知道，他们会经历各种痴迷阶段，短则几天，长则几年。我在成长过程中也经历过很多阶段。这是制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德。我曾有过短暂的火车迷时期，在学龄前，我痴迷于农用设备。我能像一位老意大利小麦农夫一样，随口列出那些冷门的欧洲拖拉机品牌。但我认为我最强烈的痴迷，和许多孩子一样，是恐龙。我五岁时对恐龙的了解比现在还要多。
And I was all but certain that I would one day become a paleontologist. I don't know exactly where this dinosaur obsession came from, but I think part of it was just that dinosaurs looked so cool. I had all these books filled with incredible drawings of colorful dinosaurs leaping around, roaring, and tearing into one another. I fell in love with the artwork in those books. And at least for the time being, art is the only way we experience dinosaurs. We can study bones and fossils, but barring the invention of time travel or some Jurassic Park Resurrection scenario, we will never see these animals with our own eyes.
而且我几乎确信自己将来会成为一名古生物学家。我不知道这种对恐龙的痴迷究竟从何而来，但我认为部分原因仅仅是因为恐龙看起来太酷了。我当时有各种各样的书，里面画满了令人难以置信的插图，画着色彩斑斓的恐龙跳跃、咆哮、互相撕咬。我爱上了那些书里的艺术作品。至少在目前，艺术是我们体验恐龙的唯一方式。我们可以研究骨骼和化石，但除非发明了时间旅行或出现某种《侏罗纪公园》式的复活场景，否则我们永远无法亲眼见到这些动物。
There are no photos or video, which means that if we want to picture how they look, someone has to draw them. Hello, I'm Dr. Robert Bucker, known to the folks in North Texas as Jurassic Bob. I dig bones, dinosaur bones. Bob Bucker is one of the most famous living paleontologists, and he also happens to be a very skilled paleo artist. He thinks the two go hand in hand. Art is very important in teaching natural history science, maybe all science. Teach everyone art, and everyone music too patterns.
没有照片或视频，这意味着如果我们想想象它们的样子，就必须有人把它们画出来。你好，我是罗伯特·巴克博士，北德克萨斯州的人们称我为“侏罗纪鲍勃”。我挖掘骨头，恐龙骨头。鲍勃·巴克是当今最著名的古生物学家之一，同时他也是一位非常出色的古生物艺术家。他认为两者相辅相成。艺术在教授自然历史科学，甚至可能在所有科学教学中都非常重要。教每个人艺术，也教每个人音乐，教他们模式。
Geez. I like Bob a lot. When I interviewed him in his studio in Boulder, Colorado, he showed up in hour early and he brought his own snacks. He's got snacks here. He's got coffee and some apple pie. Free range apple pie. This is so liberal.
天哪。我非常喜欢鲍勃。当我在他位于科罗拉多州博尔德的工作室采访他时，他提前一小时就到了，还带了自己的零食。他这儿有零食。他有咖啡和一些苹果派。散养苹果派。这太自由派了。
This place. This is so bolder. Cage free Apple Pie. Once we got started with our interview, Bob said that like me, he got obsessed with dinosaurs and dinosaur art pretty early on. How I got hooked was a piece of journalism from 1953, Life Magazine cover story called The World We live in and a pictures of dinosaurs and whatnot the cover Image was the head of a long neck dinosaur sitting in a swamp munching on grass with a stegosaurus in the background Sort of staring off into space and inside was this long article about evolution after two hours with that life magazine I announced to my startled parents,
这个地方。这太“博尔德”了。散养苹果派。采访开始后，鲍勃说，像我一样，他很早就开始痴迷于恐龙和恐龙艺术了。我入坑是因为1953年的一篇新闻报道，《生活》杂志的封面故事，题目是《我们生活的世界》，里面有恐龙之类的图片。封面图像是一个长颈恐龙的头，坐在沼泽里嚼着草，背景里有一只剑龙，看起来像是在发呆。里面有一篇关于进化的长文章。在读了那本《生活》杂志两个小时后，我向我那吃惊的父母宣布：
mom and dad I want to grow up and be a vertebrate paleontologist. And dad had no expression, and mom smiled and said, that's nice, dear, it's a stage you'll outgrow. But unlike me, dinosaurs weren't just the childhood phase for Jurassic Bob. By the time he headed off to college, a career in vertebrate paleontology was still the game plan. But it was kind of a strange time to be entering the field. In the mid-20th century, American dinosaur science was in a bit of a rut. Dinosaurs were considered big, dumb, cold-blooded reptiles. Evolutionary failures destined for extinction.
“爸爸妈妈，我长大后想成为一名脊椎动物古生物学家。”爸爸面无表情，妈妈微笑着说：“那很好，亲爱的，这只是一个阶段，你会长大的。”但与我不同的是，恐龙对“侏罗纪鲍勃”来说不仅仅是童年的一个阶段。当他上大学时，从事脊椎动物古生物学研究仍然是他的职业规划。但那是一个进入该领域的奇怪时期。在20世纪中期，美国恐龙科学陷入了某种停滞。恐龙被认为是巨大、愚蠢、冷血的爬行动物。注定灭绝的进化失败者。
And that view of dinosaurs affected how they were painted and drawn. Most of the paintings of dinosaurs, they're not moving. They're not interacting with each other. There's no spark of intelligence and social life. And their bodies were like hulking masses of flesh. The way Brontosaurus and Diplodicus, the biggest dinosaurs, were illustrated they were like giant gray vacuum cleaners,
这种对恐龙的看法影响了它们的绘画和描绘方式。大多数恐龙画作中，它们是不动的。它们之间没有互动。没有智慧和社交生活的火花。它们的身体就像笨重的肉块。雷龙和梁龙这些最大的恐龙，被描绘得就像巨大的灰色吸尘器，
with very, very short legs, and they were slowly pulling themselves across the landscape or sitting neck deep in a fetted swamp. Dinosaurs were often drawn sitting in swamps, like on that live magazine cover. The thinking was they were so large they couldn't possibly hold up their own body weight. And if they were drawn on land, they usually dragged their fat tails behind them as they walked. And that's where we were in the early 1960 early 1960s dinosaurs were sad, cold-blooded dead ends in the history of life. But paleontology was about to go through.
腿非常非常短，它们缓慢地在景观中拖行，或者坐在深及脖子的污浊沼泽里。恐龙经常被画成坐在沼泽里，就像那本《生活》杂志的封面上一样。当时的观点是，它们太大了，不可能支撑起自己的体重。如果它们被画在陆地上，它们走路时通常会拖着肥大的尾巴。这就是20世纪60年代初的情况，恐龙在生命史上是悲哀的、冷血的死胡同。但古生物学即将经历一场……
A spectacular and unanticipated U-turn. And a young Bob Bocker just off to college would find himself right in the thick of the action. Freshman year, the Yale Geology Department took me a bunch of other freshmen out today. The trip out west was led by one of Bob's professors at Yale. A paleontologist named John Ostrom. And among other things, we dug up four raptures. They were a new species of raptor that Professor Ostrum named Dynonicus.
一场壮观且意想不到的彻底转变。而刚上大学的年轻鲍勃·巴克发现自己正处于这场变革的中心。大一那年，耶鲁大学地质系带我和其他一群新生去野外考察。这次西部之行由鲍勃在耶鲁的一位教授领导。一位名叫约翰·奥斯特罗姆的古生物学家。除其他事项外，我们挖掘出了四只猛禽。它们是奥斯特罗姆教授命名为“恐爪龙”的一种新物种。
Meaning terrible claw. And the bones were found really close together. Presumably they'd lived together. They were a pack, maybe intelligent. But what really got Professor Ostrum excited was the anatomy of the skeleton. After studying the fossil remains back at Yale, Ostrum concluded that Dynonicus had not
意思是“可怕的爪子”。这些骨头被发现时靠得非常近。推测它们生活在一起。它们是一个群体，也许很聪明。但真正让奥斯特罗姆教授兴奋的是骨骼的解剖结构。在耶鲁研究了化石遗骸后，奥斯特罗姆得出结论：恐爪龙并不是
been a slow plotting swamp creature. It had been fleet-footed, agile, and extremely active. Ostrom began to argue that if you really looked at the anatomy of many dinosaurs, they looked less like lumbering lizards and more like super-athletic birds. And his student, Bob Bocker, found this idea really compelling. He remembers looking at a skeleton of a different dinosaur called Ornithelestes. He really did look like a road runner with a long-boney tail and teeth, but wow, it just spoke agility. But then you read the textbooks and you're not supposed to believe that.
一种缓慢爬行的沼泽生物。它曾是行动敏捷、极其活跃的动物。奥斯特罗姆开始论证，如果你仔细观察许多恐龙的解剖结构，它们看起来不像笨重的蜥蜴，而更像超级运动型的鸟类。他的学生鲍勃·巴克发现这个想法非常有说服力。他记得看着另一种名为“鸟脚龙”的恐龙骨骼。它看起来确实像一只走鹃，有着长长的骨质尾巴和牙齿，哇，它简直就是敏捷的代名词。但当你读教科书时，你却被告知不应该相信这一点。
As an undergraduate, Bacher dissected modern animals in an effort to better understand dinosaur musculature. And he concluded that the old stereotypes about stupid sluggish dinosaurs just didn't hold up. They weren't slow and sloppy. Now, this idea wasn't totally new. Bacher says that for decades, going back as early as the mid-19th century, there had been people saying that dinosaurs were smart, active, and bird-like. But these facts were forgotten about, really.
作为本科生，巴克解剖了现代动物，试图更好地理解恐龙的肌肉结构。他得出结论，关于恐龙愚蠢、迟钝的旧刻板印象根本站不住脚。它们并不缓慢和邋遢。现在，这个想法并不完全是新的。巴克说，几十年来，早在19世纪中期，就有人说恐龙是聪明、活跃且像鸟类的。但这些事实实际上被遗忘了。
They dropped out of textbooks. So Walker decided to publish a paper in a Yale journal and his editor says, I know what you should call this study. And I said, what? She said, you should call it the superiority of dinosaurs. I said, yeah, that's it. They weren't evolutionary husbands.
它们从教科书中消失了。所以巴克决定在耶鲁的一本期刊上发表一篇论文，他的编辑说：“我知道你应该给这项研究起什么名字。”我说：“什么？”她说：“你应该叫它《恐龙的优越性》。”我说：“对，就是这个。”它们不是进化的失败者。
They weren't dead ends in the flow of Darwinian process. They were top of the line. They beat everybody. But convincing people that dinosaurs were actually totally different than they had been depicted for the past 60 years was going to require more than a few good academic papers, to really change people's minds. Sometimes you got a show instead of tell.
它们不是达尔文进化过程中的死胡同。它们是顶级的。它们打败了所有人。但要让人们相信恐龙实际上与过去60年所描绘的完全不同，需要的不仅仅是几篇好的学术论文，要真正改变人们的想法，有时你需要展示，而不是讲述。
And remember, Bocker was a skilled illustrator as well as a scientist. And so when John Ostrom wrote his definitive paper on Dynanicus, he asked Bocker to do the illustration. And I positioned the bones as if his raptor was running. In the picture, the raptor is nearly parallel with the ground. It's left leg springing forward, it's right leg curled tightly against its torso, preparing for the next stride. The tail is high in the air, it's beautiful and kind of terrifying. Austria put the picture right on the front of his paper,
记住，巴克不仅是一位科学家，还是一位熟练的插画家。所以当约翰·奥斯特罗姆撰写关于恐爪龙的权威论文时，他请巴克来做插图。我把骨骼摆放成这只猛禽正在奔跑的样子。在图中，猛禽几乎与地面平行。它的左腿向前跃出，右腿紧紧蜷缩在躯干旁，准备下一次跨步。尾巴高高翘起，既美丽又有些恐怖。奥斯特罗姆把这张图放在了他论文的首页，
and it quickly became an iconic drawing. No one had ever seen anything quite like it. Bacca is like a renegade. This is Darren Nish, a paleontologist based in the UK. He's got like a flamboyant appearance, he insists on wearing a cowboy hat all the time, he's got a giant bushy beard, and right from the late 60s when he's starting to talk about this stuff, he's drawing these agile, active dinosaurs. Bucker finished up at Yale and went off to graduate school where he continued to speak truth to the slow, dumb, dinosaur establishment. He wrote academic and popular articles about how impressive dinosaurs had been. And he illustrated them all himself. He drew dinosaurs bounding across the prehistoric landscape like track and field stars, with
它很快成为了一幅标志性的画作。没人见过这样的东西。巴克就像一个叛逆者。这是达伦·奈什，一位常驻英国的古生物学家。他外表华丽，坚持一直戴着牛仔帽，留着浓密的络腮胡。从60年代末他开始谈论这些东西时起，他就一直在画这些敏捷、活跃的恐龙。巴克在耶鲁毕业后去了研究生院，在那里他继续向缓慢、愚蠢的恐龙学界权威说真话。他撰写了关于恐龙有多么令人印象深刻的学术和大众文章。而且他亲自为它们画插图。他画的恐龙像田径明星一样在史前景观中奔跑，有着
live muscular bodies. So prior to this time, an animal like Tyrannosaurus would have been drawn as like a guldzilla type animal dragon it's telling the ground, it's not a particularly attractive beast, but under backer you've got this thing shown with massive bulging muscles. And Bakker's athletic dinosaurs became a model for other paleo-artists. So when my dinonicus drawing appeared, some artist younger than I said, huh, okay, now we can do it. Artists like Gregory Paul embrace this new, exciting vision of dinosaurs.
充满活力的肌肉身体。所以在此之前，像霸王龙这样的动物会被画成哥斯拉那样的动物，拖着尾巴在地上走，那不是一种特别吸引人的野兽，但在巴克的笔下，你看到的是肌肉隆起的形象。巴克的运动型恐龙成为了其他古生物艺术家的典范。所以当我的恐爪龙画作出现时，一些比我年轻的艺术家说：“哈，好吧，现在我们可以这样做了。”像格雷戈里·保罗这样的艺术家拥抱了这种新的、令人兴奋的恐龙愿景。
They started giving their dinosaurs vibrant colors, and occasionally feathers to really emphasize their bird-ness. Soon images of athletic, colorful dinosaurs were everywhere. And they helped fuel the revolution that was taking place in paleontology. Throughout the 70s, more and more paleontologists got on board with Austro and Bakers theories. They found new fossils and footprint evidence suggesting that dinosaurs have been more blooded, intelligent, and bird-like. This period has become known as the dinosaur renaissance, a moment when we totally rethought
他们开始给恐龙涂上鲜艳的颜色，有时还会加上羽毛，以真正强调它们的鸟类特征。很快，运动型、色彩鲜艳的恐龙图像随处可见。它们推动了古生物学界正在发生的革命。在整个70年代，越来越多的古生物学家加入了奥斯特罗姆和巴克的理论阵营。他们发现了新的化石和足迹证据，表明恐龙是温血的、聪明的、像鸟类的。这一时期被称为“恐龙文艺复兴”，一个我们彻底重新思考
all of our assumptions about these incredible prehistoric animals. In Derenneich, things art was a huge part of its success. I think that part of the reason that the dinosaurs of the dinosaur were nice ones, the dinosaurs of Auschmann and Bacchus, drew in so many scientists in the 1670s was because it was accompanied by brilliant visuals. If anyone missed out on this scientific revolution and still thought that dinosaurs were slow and stupid, that ended in 1993. The dinosaurs in Jurassic Park are very active.
关于这些不可思议的史前动物的所有假设的时刻。在达伦·奈什看来，艺术是其成功的巨大组成部分。我认为恐龙文艺复兴时期的恐龙，即奥斯特罗姆和巴克的恐龙，之所以在60、70年代吸引了这么多科学家，部分原因是因为它伴随着精彩的视觉效果。如果有人错过了这场科学革命，仍然认为恐龙缓慢而愚蠢，那么这种想法在1993年结束了。《侏罗纪公园》里的恐龙非常活跃。
The Dinosaur's of Jurassic Park in 1993, they are the dinosaur renaissance. And when that movie came out, the whole world got to see these fierce, athletic creatures running through kitchens and eating lawyers off of toilets. And once you've seen the dinosaurs in Jurassic Park, you can't unsee them. I think it cemented the notion of athletic dinosaurs. This is John Conway. He draws dinosaurs for a living. I'm a paleo artist, which means that I draw and paint prehistoric animals. Conway got interested in paleo art after reading Bob B Barker's book, The Dinosaur Heresies. And in the early part of his career, he drew dinosaurs that looked a lot like Barker's,
1993年《侏罗纪公园》里的恐龙，它们就是恐龙文艺复兴的产物。当那部电影上映时，全世界都看到了这些凶猛、运动型的生物在厨房里奔跑，把律师从厕所里叼走。一旦你看了《侏罗纪公园》里的恐龙，你就无法忘记它们。我认为它巩固了运动型恐龙的概念。这是约翰·康威。他以画恐龙为生。我是一名古生物艺术家，这意味着我绘制和绘画史前动物。康威在读了鲍勃·巴克的书《恐龙异端》后对古生物艺术产生了兴趣。在他职业生涯的早期，他画的恐龙看起来很像巴克的，
super lean and mussely. But after a while, he started to feel kind of funny about it. He says that all of his dinosaurs looked like they had been shrink-wrapped. You know, they suction, pack, you pack your clothes and you put the vacuum cleaner on it and you suck all the air out and it shrinks it down. That's sort of what we were doing with dinosaurs. We were sort of putting skin on them and then vacuuming out anything that was in between that skin and the muscles. Now paleoartis weren't just doing that to make their dinosaurs look all cool and buff.
超级精瘦且肌肉发达。但过了一段时间，他开始觉得有点不对劲。他说他所有的恐龙看起来都像是被“真空包装”了。你知道，你把衣服装进袋子，用吸尘器把空气抽干，它就会收缩。我们对恐龙做的就是那样。我们给它们贴上皮肤，然后把皮肤和肌肉之间的所有东西都抽干了。现在，古生物艺术家这样做不仅仅是为了让恐龙看起来很酷、很强壮。
They were trying to be accurate. I am part of the generation of paleoartis that grew up from a young age when we first started to think that it really mattered to get things right. And to get things right, you want your art to be rooted in real scientific evidence. And the main piece of evidence was often a skeleton. Paleoartists would base the shape of their dinosaurs on an accurate skeleton. The bones give you a pretty good idea where the muscles should go, but soft tissues like skin, and cartilage, and fat are much harder. Fat usually doesn't survive for millions of years in
他们试图做到准确。我是那一代古生物艺术家中的一员，我们从小就开始认为把事情搞对真的很重要。为了搞对，你希望你的艺术植根于真实的科学证据。而主要的证据通常是骨骼。古生物艺术家会根据准确的骨骼来确定恐龙的形状，但皮肤、软骨和脂肪等软组织要难得多。脂肪通常不会在数百万年的
fossils. And so, without any evidence of it, paleoartists tended to be pretty conservative about how much fat they gave their dinosaurs. Which makes total sense, you're not going to add something that you don't have evidence for. But the result was that all these dinosaurs looked like they went to the gym three times a day, and drank protein shakes for every meal. John Conway says it began to feel as though paleoartists had replaced one orthodoxy with another. At some point, I thought, you know, we can't just keep doing this. This is not interesting in many ways. And is it even right? Is this conservative approach really giving people the right notion about what dinosaurs looked like? Just because fat didn't survive for millions of years doesn't mean that a dinosaur didn't have it. They are animals after all.
化石中保存下来。因此，在没有任何证据的情况下，古生物艺术家在给恐龙添加多少脂肪方面往往非常保守。这完全说得通，你不会添加没有证据的东西。但结果是，所有这些恐龙看起来都像是每天去健身房三次，每顿饭都喝蛋白粉。约翰·康威说，他开始觉得古生物艺术家似乎用一种正统观念取代了另一种。在某个时刻，我想：“你知道，我们不能一直这样下去。这在很多方面都不有趣。而且这真的对吗？这种保守的方法真的给了人们关于恐龙样子的正确概念吗？”仅仅因为脂肪没有保存数百万年，并不意味着恐龙没有脂肪。毕竟它们是动物。
So animals have fat and they have it all over the place and some places they have really big fat reserve, which changes their shape fairly drastically. To underscore this point, Conway asked me to consider a thought experiment. If we reconstructed modern animals, like we reconstruct dinosaurs, what would they look like? In other words, if some alien paleontologist from
所以动物有脂肪，而且到处都有，在某些地方它们有非常大的脂肪储备，这会相当剧烈地改变它们的形状。为了强调这一点，康威让我考虑一个思想实验。如果我们像重建恐龙一样重建现代动物，它们会是什么样子？换句话说，如果某个来自
millions of years in the future was to try and draw a modern animal, like say a whale or a camel, just from their fossilized skeleton, how would it look? Well, if you actually do it, the modern animals look ridiculous. If you draw a bowhead whale, for example, just from the skeleton, without a lot of fat or blubber, it looks kind of like a giant tadpole with a bulbous head and a long, snake-like tail. I mean, you take away all that stuff and you're not left with much whale, because whales, their shape is defined by fat.
数百万年后的外星古生物学家试图仅凭化石骨骼来绘制一种现代动物，比如鲸鱼或骆驼，它会是什么样子？好吧，如果你真的这样做，现代动物看起来会很荒谬。例如，如果你只根据骨骼画一只弓头鲸，没有大量的脂肪或鲸脂，它看起来就像一只巨大的蝌蚪，有着球状的头和长长的、像蛇一样的尾巴。我的意思是，你拿走所有那些东西，剩下的鲸鱼就不多了，因为鲸鱼的形状是由脂肪定义的。
Dinosaurs also had fat, and John argues that it would have changed their shape pretty dramatically. Who knows, some might have even had humps like camels. Yeah, you could take one of the most familiar dinosaurs. That dinosaur could have camel humps, and we wouldn't know. Right? Because you can't tell from a camel's back that it has humps. You just can't. There's not really anything there. Brontosaurus could have humps? We don't know. Now scientists do sometimes find dinosaur fossils with
恐龙也有脂肪，约翰认为这会相当剧烈地改变它们的形状。谁知道呢，有些甚至可能有像骆驼那样的驼峰。是的，你可以拿一种最熟悉的恐龙。那只恐龙可能有骆驼那样的驼峰，而我们却不知道。对吧？因为你从骆驼的背上看不出它有驼峰。你就是看不出来。那里其实没什么东西。雷龙可能有驼峰吗？我们不知道。现在科学家有时会发现带有
the soft tissues intact, and when they do, they can completely change our image of the animal. The dinosaur Cetacosaurus, for example, used to be depicted in a standard shrink-wrapped kind of way. Until paleontologists found this amazing full-body fossil, where lots of the fat and the skin and the different soft tissues had been perfectly preserved. Turns out. The fleshy outline around the body was quite extensive. It was quite a chubby creature. There's striping all over the place, all over the body. And growing off the top of the tail, it's got like a hundred long curving quills.
软组织完好的恐龙化石，当他们发现时，它们可以彻底改变我们对这种动物的形象。例如，鹦鹉嘴龙过去常以一种标准的“真空包装”方式被描绘。直到古生物学家发现了这个惊人的全身化石，其中大量的脂肪、皮肤和各种软组织被完美地保存了下来。结果发现，身体周围的肉质轮廓相当宽大。它是一个相当胖乎乎的生物。全身到处都是条纹。而且在尾巴顶部，长着大约一百根长长的弯曲刚毛。
They look kind of like floppy porcupine quills. And like you add all that together, that's a creature that's... we just would not predict that, based on just finding bones alone. In recent years, fossils have been found with fat and frills and thick coats of feathers. We more than anyone had predicted. So it turns out every time we discover something like this, it's weird. And that caught me thinking, so if all the ones we've discovered so far have turned out
它们看起来有点像松软的豪猪刺。你把所有这些加在一起，那是一个……我们仅仅根据发现骨头是绝对无法预测的生物。近年来，人们发现了带有脂肪、褶边和厚厚羽毛层的化石。比我们任何人预测的都要多。所以事实证明，每次我们发现这样的东西，它都很奇怪。这让我开始思考，如果到目前为止我们发现的所有恐龙都证明
to be pretty weird, what does that tell us about the rest of them? So John began to draw something new with his art. He started to speculate. He started drawing pudgy dinosaurs and dinosaurs with pumps and quills and weird skin flaps. And that was my rule. It was how far can we go? What's the most outrageous thing I can do that we don't know, isn't true, right? It's still within the realms of possibility. It's not falsify. John wasn't just making stuff up out of thin air. It was like there was a standard conservative dinosaur at the center of his drawings, and then Kameh would cover it with more speculative elements. It wasn't claiming that every drawing he did was perfectly accurate,
是相当奇怪的，那这告诉了我们关于其余恐龙的什么信息呢？所以约翰开始用他的艺术画一些新的东西。他开始推测。他开始画胖乎乎的恐龙，以及带有驼峰、刚毛和奇怪皮肤褶皱的恐龙。这就是我的规则。我们可以走多远？我能做的最离谱的事情是什么，而我们又不知道它不是真的，对吧？它仍然在可能性的范围内。它不是伪造的。约翰并不是凭空捏造。就像他的画作中心有一个标准的保守恐龙，然后康威会用更多推测性的元素覆盖它。他并不是声称他画的每一幅画都是完全准确的，
but he wanted to show people that dinosaurs as a group probably had a lot more weird variety than we think. And so, to get the overall picture of dinosaurs right, I think you need a healthy dose of speculation in there. Conway says that dinosaur art should always reflect the latest science, what we know for sure, but we'll never know everything. And I think the speculation is about
但他想向人们展示，恐龙作为一个群体，可能比我们想象的要有更多的奇怪多样性。因此，为了得到恐龙的整体正确图景，我认为你需要适量的推测。康威说，恐龙艺术应该始终反映最新的科学，即我们确切知道的东西，但我们永远不会知道一切。我认为推测是关于
what extra bits of weird beauty were in the world back then. That we'll just never know about. The role of the artist is to bring back some of that real magic as a prehistoric world that was certainly there. John eventually decided to give the world some of that magic in the form of a book. He teamed up with Darren Nash and another paleo artist named Memo Cosmon and published a slim little paperback called All Yesterday's. All yesterday's is filled with dinosaurs that look very different from what you're used to. There's a triceratops that's covered in spines, a magungosaurus with skin that camouflages
当时世界上还存在哪些额外的奇怪美感。我们只是永远不会知道。艺术家的角色是带回一些史前世界真正存在的魔力。约翰最终决定以书的形式给世界带来一些那种魔力。他与达伦·奈什和另一位名叫梅莫·科斯蒙的古生物艺术家合作，出版了一本名为《昨日之恐龙》的薄薄平装书。《昨日之恐龙》里充满了与你习惯看到的非常不同的恐龙。有一只长满尖刺的三角龙，一只皮肤可以伪装
it against the forest floor, and a pharaohzina-saurus that is so covered in feathers it looks like a haystack. And next to each image, the artist describes why they drew it that way. The camouflage dinosaur is drawn that way because the artist reason that its oddly proportioned body might have made it vulnerable to predators, and in need of some kind of defense strategy. All yesterdays was a big hit, and it helped spark a little movement for more speculative paleoart. We talk about the all yesterdays movement as like is the new frontier of the way we should
在森林地面的马君龙，还有一只长满羽毛看起来像干草堆的镰刀龙。在每张图片旁边，艺术家描述了他们为什么那样画。那只伪装的恐龙之所以那样画，是因为艺术家推断它比例奇怪的身体可能使它容易受到捕食者的攻击，因此需要某种防御策略。《昨日之恐龙》大获成功，它帮助引发了一场关于更具推测性的古生物艺术的小运动。我们谈论《昨日之恐龙》运动，就像它是我们应该
depict prehistoric animals. Daring Niche says it's more acceptable now to draw a dinosaur based on a hypothesis. For example, horned dinosaurs like triceratops have these absurdly large nostrils that have confused paleontologists for years. There have been a few different hypotheses but forward by scientists. And one of them is that the dinosaurs may have had inflatable nose balloons. Kind of like elephant seal or hooded seal inflatable pouches, but just would have looked weird and grotesque and utterly alien to us, but that's a very real possibility.
描绘史前动物的新前沿。达伦·奈什说，现在基于假设来画恐龙更容易被接受。例如，像三角龙这样的有角恐龙有这些大得离谱的鼻孔，多年来一直困扰着古生物学家。科学家们提出了几种不同的假设。其中之一是恐龙可能有可充气的鼻气球。有点像象海豹或冠海豹的可充气囊，但这看起来会很奇怪、怪诞，对我们来说完全陌生，但这是一种非常真实的可能性。
Now, 20 years ago, if someone were to draw at Triceratops with nose balloons, they would have been laughed at. But I would say that what we call the all yesterday's movement means that it is now quite reasonable for an artist to say, I've shown my Triceratops with giant inflatable nose balloons for this reason. And you could say, no, don't do it, that's too speculative, that it would be equally justifiable to say, okay, for the time being, that's okay. That doesn't mean triceratops definitely had nose balloons.
现在，20年前，如果有人画一只带有鼻气球的三角龙，他们会被嘲笑。但我会说，我们所说的《昨日之恐龙》运动意味着，现在艺术家说“我出于这个原因展示了带有巨大可充气鼻气球的三角龙”是非常合理的。你可以说：“不，别这样做，这太推测性了。”但同样可以说：“好吧，目前为止，这没问题。”这并不意味着三角龙肯定有鼻气球。
But by drawing it that way, it's like the artist is asking us to keep an open mind. Because even though we know a lot about the prehistoric world, and more and more every day, the science is always changing. The past is always a moving target. Piliwart is not just about drawing dinosaurs with stripes and nose balloons. Illustrators also depict dinosaur behavior, which may have even a greater impact on how we imagine extinct animals. More on that, after this.
但通过那样画，就像艺术家在要求我们保持开放的心态。因为尽管我们对史前世界了解很多，而且每天都在增加，但科学总是在变化。过去总是一个移动的目标。古生物艺术不仅仅是画带有条纹和鼻气球的恐龙。插画家还描绘恐龙的行为，这可能对我们如何想象灭绝动物有更大的影响。稍后继续。
Hello, this is Emmett, back with Roman in the studio to talk a little bit more about Paleoart. Hi, Roman. In this piece, we focused a lot on dinosaur appearance, like the look of their physical bodies, but there's like a, now they're pretty important issue with this, which is dinosaur behavior. Like if you're going to draw a dinosaur, you're going to draw it. It's doing something. Doing something, right? Right.
你好，我是埃米特，回到演播室和罗曼一起多聊聊古生物艺术。嗨，罗曼。在这篇文章中，我们重点关注了恐龙的外观，比如它们身体的样子，但这里有一个现在非常重要的问题，那就是恐龙的行为。就像如果你要画一只恐龙，你肯定会画它。它在做某事。做某事，对吧？对。
And so like when you think of like dinosaur art, what are the dinosaurs usually doing? Usually the T-Rex is tearing something apart. Usually the, at least when I was a kid, the Brontosaurus, as we mentioned, was staining a swamp with leaves sort of hanging out of its mouth. Right, like if it's like a meeting dinosaur, it's probably eating another dinosaur, or attacking another dinosaur. If it's a plant eating dinosaur,
所以当你想到恐龙艺术时，恐龙通常在做什么？通常霸王龙在撕碎什么东西。通常，至少在我小时候，我们提到的雷龙，正站在沼泽里，嘴里挂着叶子。对，就像如果它是一只食肉恐龙，它可能正在吃另一只恐龙，或者攻击另一只恐龙。如果它是一只食草恐龙，
it's probably being attacked, or like running away in some kind of way. Or eating a plant. I mean, it sort of seems to be like whatever you ate as a dinosaur is what you should be depicted doing at any moment of its being depicted in form of art. Which like, you know, I mean, in some ways,
它可能正在被攻击，或者以某种方式逃跑。或者在吃植物。我的意思是，无论你作为恐龙吃什么，似乎都应该是它在艺术形式中被描绘时正在做的事情。这就像，你知道，我的意思是，在某些方面，
it's not just a dinosaur thing. Like if you think about nature documentaries, we like to depict action. Totally. Like one was the last time you saw a cheetah doing anything other than running down a gazelle and like biting its throat. Right.
这不仅仅是恐龙的问题。就像如果你想到自然纪录片，我们喜欢描绘动作。完全正确。就像你上次看到猎豹除了追赶瞪羚并咬住它的喉咙之外还在做任何事情是什么时候。对。
But like cheetahs do a lot of other things. Sure. They have a complex life. A whole life. And that's like a real point though with art for people like Darren and John who are in our piece is like they think the lives of a lot of animals, including dinosaurs are a lot less action packed than it feels like when you are just looking at the art.
但猎豹确实做了很多其他事情。当然。它们有复杂的生活。完整的生活。对于像达伦和约翰这样出现在我们文章中的人来说，这是一个真正的观点，他们认为许多动物（包括恐龙）的生活远没有你在看艺术作品时感觉到的那么充满动作。
They're not opening their mouths and roaring at the camera all the time. They're not just killing and fighting. They're doing things that living animals do. They're like, you know, moving around and sleeping and finding food and being boring all the time. And you mentioned this earlier, but like I feel like of all the dinosaurs that we don't associate with that kind of boring activity, like Tyrannosaurus Rex, ranks pretty high. Of all the ones we associate with action and violence, it's T-Rex. Absolutely. It's always chomping at something.
它们不会一直张着嘴对着镜头咆哮。它们不仅仅是在杀戮和战斗。它们在做活着的动物会做的事情。它们就像，你知道，四处走动、睡觉、寻找食物，而且一直很无聊。你之前提到了这一点，但我感觉在所有我们不与那种无聊活动联系在一起的恐龙中，比如霸王龙，排名相当高。在所有我们与动作和暴力联系在一起的恐龙中，它是霸王龙。绝对是。它总是咬着什么东西。
That's its role. Even the end of Jurassic Park, its role is to end the movie by Chomping a dinosaur in it. Right, right. And so when Darren and John were writing the book all yesterday, they obviously wanted to put a Tyrannosaurus in there. And John based his T-Rex painting on this one skeleton, this kind of famous skeleton
这就是它的角色。即使在《侏罗纪公园》的结尾，它的角色也是通过咬死一只恐龙来结束电影。对，对。所以当达伦和约翰在写《昨日之恐龙》这本书时，他们显然想在里面放一只霸王龙。约翰根据这具骨骼画了他的霸王龙，这具著名的骨骼
that scientists have nicknamed Stan. Stan is quite an aggressive looking tyrannosaurus in a way. It's got quite a large, long, scary looking head. And so Stan is traditionally depicted doing very nasty things to other animals. But John is also pretty adamant like that's not the whole truth of who this creature was. They're probably going to kill something
科学家们给它起了个绰号叫“斯坦”。斯坦在某种程度上是一只看起来非常有侵略性的霸王龙。它有一个相当大、长、看起来很吓人的头。所以斯坦传统上被描绘成对其他动物做非常恶劣的事情。但约翰也非常坚持，那并不是这个生物是谁的全部真相。它们可能每两周
once every two weeks. They spent the vast majority of their life asleep probably with a great big full belly just sleeping on the ground. And so that's how I painted it. So do you have that picture in the book? Yeah, yeah. So here's the book. Oh, you look so peaceful. Yeah, it's almost like a cute image. It's very cute. Yeah, just slightly crawled up with its little tiny T-Rex arms up by its chin. This is one of John's favorite pieces from all yesterday's and he calls it a sleepy stan. Well, in fact, I mean, this picture, it doesn't even show his teeth when it's sleeping.
杀一次东西。它们一生中绝大部分时间可能都在睡觉，肚子吃得饱饱的，就躺在地上睡觉。所以这就是我画它的方式。那么书里有那张照片吗？有，有。这是书。哦，你看上去真平静。是的，这几乎像是一个可爱的形象。非常可爱。是的，它的小小的霸王龙手臂蜷缩在下巴旁。这是约翰在《昨日之恐龙》中最喜欢的作品之一，他称之为“睡着的斯坦”。事实上，我的意思是，这张照片，它睡觉时甚至没有露出牙齿。
Yeah. Which I don't think I've ever seen a T-Rex picture without it bearing its teeth Right, which is a stunning to think about that I've never and I but I now as I see it I know it's true I've never seen one without its teeth being being being shown and how long they are and Probably ripping into flesh, but yeah, we just we don't show Tell me in a story. I just Relaxing and that's what they did most of the time. Right.
是的。我想我从来没见过不露牙齿的霸王龙图片。对，想到这一点真是令人震惊，我从来没见过，但现在我看到了，我知道这是真的，我从来没见过不露牙齿的，而且它们的牙齿有多长，可能正在撕裂肉体，但是的，我们只是……我们不展示它在休息的故事。而这正是它们大部分时间在做的事情。对。
There's probably pretty good life. Sleepy Stan. Sleepy Stan. Curled up. That's awesome. So if you flip Roman to like the back of the book, there's one more thing that I want to show you. So this back section of the book is actually called All Todays. And the idea behind this part of the book is it's sort of the actualization of that thought experiment that John Conway asked us to do, where you know you're imagining an alien paleontologist from the future who is trying to piece together what the contemporary world, the animals of the contemporary world, look like based on fossil evidence.
那可能是一种相当不错的生活。睡着的斯坦。睡着的斯坦。蜷缩着。太棒了。所以如果你翻到书的后面，罗曼，还有一件事我想给你看。书的这一后半部分实际上叫《今日之恐龙》。这一部分的理念是，它有点像约翰·康威让我们做的那个思想实验的实现，你知道，你想象一个来自未来的外星古生物学家，他正试图根据化石证据拼凑出当代世界、当代世界的动物是什么样子的。
Right. So this picture I'm looking at now is a manatee, but it's a land, a grazing land, herbivore. Right, can you read the description they have there? It says, a solitary manatee is shown grazing in its mountain home. We only know the skull of this enigmatic herbivore. So basically, like in this case, they're saying, like, so with this animal, maybe we only, the only thing we ever got was the skull. And so, like, from that, you're trying to make, you're like, oh, this looks a little bit like a cow skull. And it's totally common in dinosaurs, that they only find one little section. It's very rare that we find full skeletons to tell you everything about them. But, you know, we told
对。所以我现在看到的这张照片是一只海牛，但它是一只陆地上的、吃草的食草动物。对，你能读一下他们那里的描述吗？它说：“一只孤独的海牛被展示在它的山地家园中吃草。我们只知道这种神秘食草动物的头骨。”所以基本上，在这种情况下，他们是说，对于这种动物，也许我们唯一得到的就是头骨。所以，从那一点出发，你试图制造，你就像，“哦，这看起来有点像牛的头骨。”这在恐龙中非常普遍，他们只发现一小部分。我们很少能找到完整的骨骼来告诉你关于它们的一切。但是，你知道，我们被告知
that you could pick up a manatee skull and show enough, you would think that's a cow. And even if you do find a full skeleton, there are other things that you could still miss. Totally. Oh, and this elephant, you wouldn't have a trunk to as evidence of this elephant, it's just this snub-nosed, weird-looking thing. Oh my God, oh, that's so true. Right, so like a camel, the same way that we don't,
你可以拿起一个海牛头骨，你会认为那是一头牛。即使你确实找到了完整的骨骼，还有其他你仍然可能错过的东西。完全正确。哦，这头大象，你不会有象鼻作为这头大象的证据，它只是这个塌鼻子、看起来很奇怪的东西。天哪，哦，那太真实了。对，就像骆驼一样，同样的方式，我们不……
and that's that we wouldn't necessarily know that a camel had a had-humps, you wouldn't know that an elephant had trunk, had a trunk which is like such an iconic, weird piece of anatomy in the world. It's the thing that you define an elephant by, but it's not there and therefore, it doesn't look at all like an elephant
我们不一定会知道骆驼有驼峰，你不会知道大象有象鼻，象鼻是世界上如此标志性、奇怪的解剖结构。它是你定义大象的东西，但它不在那里，因此，它看起来一点也不像大象，
and it just looks absurd. I really like it. It really sells it, especially with these speculative imaginings of modern animals, really sells the idea of it a lot. Right, and they go, I like their text on some of these, so if you read the swans, yeah, say two swans are seen with their long, sith-like forelimbs, which they must have used to spear small prey items.
它看起来很荒谬。我真的很喜欢它。它真的很卖座，特别是这些对现代动物的推测性想象，真的卖座了很多。对，他们去……我喜欢他们对其中一些的文字，所以如果你读天鹅的，是的，说：“两只天鹅被看到长着长长的、像镰刀一样的前肢，它们一定是用这些来刺穿小猎物。”
One of them has just caught a tadpole, one of the mysterious fish of the past. Oh, it's so perfect. Right, so they really embody this futuristic scientist who's trying to piece together the world that we currently live in now and is making these kind of conceptual leaps from evidence to painting a real picture of what the world actually looked like. Yeah, but there's still everyone's doing their best. It's not like making fun of them. It really is. It just has to, with the limited information we have,
其中一只刚刚抓到一只蝌蚪，那是过去神秘的鱼类之一。哦，太完美了。对，所以他们真的体现了这位试图拼凑我们目前生活的世界的未来科学家，并且正在从证据到描绘世界实际样子的真实图景中进行这种概念上的飞跃。是的，但每个人都在尽力而为。这不像是在取笑他们。它确实是。它只是必须，在有限的信息下，
this is what we create. Right. And it really shows the limits of that information. Oh, it's so cool. It's such a good idea to think this way. It dislodges the iconography from your mind to be free. Exactly. You have to think about them in lots of ways. And that's really, and it really sells it when you see a modern animal depicted in the Swarche traditional dinosaur way. I kind of love that aspect of it. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Emmett Fitzgerald, Mix and Tech Production by Sharif Yusuf, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer Kurt Colstead, is the digital director.
这就是我们创造的东西。对。它真的显示了这些信息的局限性。哦，太酷了。这样思考真是一个好主意。它将图标从你的脑海中移开，让你自由。正是如此。你必须以多种方式思考它们。当你看到一只以那种传统的恐龙方式描绘的现代动物时，它真的很卖座。我有点喜欢它的那个方面。《99% Invisible》本周由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德制作，混音和技术制作由谢里夫·优素福完成，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。
The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffleman, Taren Mazza, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced, on Radio Robe. In beautiful, downtown downtown Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. You can find mall at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too.
团队的其他成员包括高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、塔伦·马扎、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李和我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在“Radio Robe”制作。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。《99% Invisible》是PRX旗下“Radio Topia”的成员，这是一个汇集了播客界最具创新性节目的独立集体。你可以在radiotopia.fm找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIOrg。我们在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也有账号。
But if you're thinking, I need more 99PI in my life, or we have all the old episodes available in new articles about design every couple of days on our beautiful, beautiful website. It's 99p i dot org Radio tapio From PRX you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但如果你在想，“我的生活中需要更多的99PI”，或者我们有所有旧剧集，每隔几天就会在我们的美丽网站上发布关于设计的新文章。网址是99pi.org。Radio Topia，来自PRX。你……本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。